the only black male anchor on fox news
is speaking out about alleged racial
discrimination at the cable channel
kelly rights claims are part of a
class-action lawsuit filed this week
against Fox News at least eleven current
and former employees accused executives
of fostering a quote culture of severe
racial harassment the suit says Fox
ignored their complaints for years now
FoxNews denies the claims and says quote
we will vigorously defend these cases an
emotional right yesterday explained his
decision to join the suit I want to make
it possible for whoever feels my shoes
that next generation to never go through
this only on CBS is warning Kelly Wright
is here along with his attorney that's
Douglas Webb door who is representing
the plaintiffs in the case welcome
gentlemen to the table this morning
Kelly I want to start with you that
seemed to be a very emotional and
painful moment for you yesterday
you've been at Fox since 2003 what
prompted you to join now and talk talk
to me and talk to us about the emotion
from yesterday
well I'll first begin with what prompted
me to come forward and that was what
took place with Monica Tichina and
Tabriz those are three other black web
yeah they were the ones who actually
ignited this this lawsuit because of
what happened in their department and
that hurt me grieve me because I thought
about collectively how behind the scenes
many of us have gone to the water cooler
around our computers and we've talked
about not just their plight but the
plight of other people of color at the
company and how there have been little
remarks like well gee Kelly if you're
blonde you could probably anchor
full-time here Monday through Friday and
comments like that began to really sting
me especially when I was trying to work
within the framework of the company
talking to my leaders saying look we're
better than this we can do better than
this even from a sound business decision
let's reach out to all people and and
I'm raising my hands as the only black
male anchor that you have right now to
say put me in the game
give me the opportunities to do more and
we and I thought we were really going to
try to do that but
your language is very strong because the
lawsuit says a cover your skin you were
quote effectively sideline and asked to
perform the role of a jim crow that's
very very explosive language it's very
explosive in language and it actually
comes from my attorney my language would
have been more like I wanted to meet the
demands that they had on me show up to
work and perform my work at thousand
percent which is what I've done and work
at any task that they had given me which
is what I've tried to do whether it be
covering the war in Iraq or doing an
overnight report where there's breaking
news about Malaysia or terrorist strike
but emotionally what got to me was the
fact that these are people that I know
people that I care about
there are hardworking people there even
the leaders there but what's happened is
the leaders have not effectively pursued
I think the diversity and inclusion of
all people in terms of turning a blind
eye to equality over all spectrums of
our shows that's the point you make
clear in the complaint that you raise
these questions I did the leaders before
heatedly and what was the response was
it to the response was no the response
was actually at some point they even
agreed with it I think well gee I'm not
talking out of both sides of my mouth
here you're actually sitting across the
table you agree with me that we should
have a program that talks about hope
that we should have a program that lifts
up all boats and that we don't just
negatively focus on what happens that's
wrong in the black community or Latino
community but we can also show positive
things that are going on in those
communities to turn the negativity
around and you suggested those type of
story of course and Kelly wasn't the
only one that was complaining I mean the
people that he referenced earlier the
three people who started this complaint
and others we represent 13 people right
now had been complaining for years since
2008 complaining about the racist
behavior of Judy Slater they complained
directly to the chief lawyer
Diane Brandie the General Counsel and
she didn't do anything about it year
after year and I hear I'm curious about
specifics yeah so Judy Slater would have
black people trying to arm-wrestle she
would when people would say good night
to her she would put her hands up and
say don't shoot mocking the blacks lives
mat matter movement she would say things
like somebody who had three kids are
they fathered by the same fighting black
men the
yeah what all black men are wifebeaters
really asking black people that
pronounce words repeat after me
so really abhorrent behavior it was
stunning and really heartbreaking to
watch the press conference
that you had yesterday Douglas let me
ask you what has happened new since
yesterday
well we've received many many calls from
people both on-air talent and people
behind the scenes as well so this is
wrong this has grown yeah at Fox News
and Fox affiliates as well and I expect
in the coming days or the coming weeks
we'll be having more announcements about
new people who are joining this race
discrimination lawsuit as it continues
to grow its systemic there any
discussions yet about any type of
settlement from the attorneys at 24 2105
no there isn't
and you know they issued a statement
yesterday calling these copycat
complaints well this is really just
systemic it's a class-action suit it is
you're still working there Kelly it's
been my experience far as I know when
you sue the company that normally
doesn't go so well what is that going to
be like for you working under those
circumstances where the company knows
how you feel about them look my mother
was so proud when I got that job my
mother remains proud of me even though
she's no longer here with me before mom
died she said you will enrich Fox they
will enrich you and I always thought it
was about monetary stuff but what it was
really about was trying to enrich the
culture and trying to rich myself as a
human being I trust and believe that God
through all of this will get glory out
of this by unifying not just employees
of Fox News but this country this racial
divide that's going on yeah we can talk
about Fox News but it's happening
everywhere and we as Americans have got
to start standing up and saying enough
is enough
I hope that the r-word racism will
become like the n-word and never using
our vocabulary ever again what to do
that I'll fall on the sword and lead
that struggle because what happened to
my fellow employees and what's happening
to some of the employees now who are
afraid to come out and talk and I
understand why because they have
families they have jobs and they don't
want to run the risk of retaliation they
don't want to run the risk of falling
into some sort of bankruptcy or whatever
my wife and I've been poor before we'll
be poor again if we have to but we want
to be rich in our
character and rich in our love for this
country and for the employees and even
the leaders that I work with the Fox
News and a fox tries to retaliate I can
assure you they're going to be hearing
from me right now I'm ready to work
I'd let's wing dirt thank you thank you
for a very shaky goes thank you thank
you